[Musique]
le scientifique Anthony Fossy vous savez
le conseiller santé de la Maison Blanche
le variant micro-ondes se déchaîne ce
virus est extraordinaire il va prendre
le dessus si le Conseil Scientifique dit
demain il faut aller vers la vaccination
obligatoire je suis vrai le Conseil le
patient final et la dernière étape avant
la vaccination on sait ce que ça veut
dire le virus au micro
en fait
résiste au vaccin alors on va nous
vacciner trois quatre dix fois et
ensuite on va découvrir que au micro de
toute façon échappe au maximum c'est
même pire que ce qu'on craignait les
Anglais encore eux viennent de donner
des chiffres en virée alors attention de
frissonnez pas mais après deux doses de
Pfizer l'efficacité n'est que de 19%, et
on parle d'une efficacité deux semaines
après deux doses avec astrazenecka
l'efficacité nue après de doses donc
vraiment contre micron de dose ça suffit
pas les données sont aujourd'hui est
disponible contre au micro-ondes une
fois le rappel effectué donc 2 + 1 2
doses puis à peu près 70 75% contre
l'infection
avant de passer au vaccin obligatoire
mais demandez
aucune responsabilité lourde on fait une
faute politique Agnès panier runachier
positive à la covid 19 la ministre
chargée de l'industrie l'a annoncé sur
Twitter et donc placé à les œufs à
l'isolement mais continue d'assurer ses
fonctions ministérielles à distance
l'idée nous vient de Sarah une jeune
rouennaise de 20 ans qui a trouvé une
méthode
un parent les hommes insistant je vous
présente la technique
du Lago je républicaine elle doit
pouvoir parler d'immigration dire par
exemple que aujourd'hui il faut arrêter
l'immigration il faut appuyer sur le
bouton STOP il faut faire une pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle représente l'archange saint Michel
terrassant le dragon une illustration
religieuse de la lutte contre le mal
mais dans les six prochains mois cette
statue devrait être déplacée
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
la décision de la démonter vient
pourtant d'être prise par le tribunal
administratif de Nantes un jugement
salué par la Fédération laïque la libre
pensée qui avait saisi la justice dès
janvier 2019 au Philippines le bilan
s'alourdi à 208 morts après le passage
du typhon raï c'est l'un des phénomènes
naturels les plus meurtriers de ces
dernières années dans le pays 239
personnes sont blessées et 52 autres
sont portés disparus les dégâts sont
colossaude le retour sur Terre de deux
touristes japonais qui ont passé 12
jours à bord de l'ISS ils sont sortis du
module Soyouz au Kazakhstan avec un
cosmonaute russe